>> OLEAD THE
HOLLOOERS
GUILD INY AN
SAME ISSUEE ALSO SBY, THDEMAND G
WAS TH
>> JOINING KNEE NOW TO BRY C F
CHANGES FOR JOINING UENCOURAGEM
TARS GUILD AND
WHERE DO TALKS STANDIT
SAG-AFTRA, THE A
DO ACTORT AT THATABL
YOAGAIN.
ITT FOR
- OUR AROUND FOUR ORS FOR TWO.
INVITED TO GEO
THE TITA AS TH END OF ING TO B
THATNVD  TO THE TABLE, ANAVD TOP
TO BE
RICA IS PA
HOANY TIME YOU'RE ACTU
CAN EN.NOLKOTHAPPEN.
>> YEA THE AORS
VUA UNID  DEMONSTRATED  A LARGY
DO YOU THINK THAT UNITY  GOING
ONE SIDR AGREEMEN THE
DEVELOPITHAT IT DOES
HER
TOUNITED.
I OPERATION RESUCE HOPE THAT WE
D SAY THAT 75%, 80% OF
THOSE ISSUES ARE OUR ISSUEAS
WELL.
THEY HAVHE THOD ONY CARIFESTYAY.
LE PLALI
CAN HOPEFULLY HELP O
AUDIENCE -OUR AUDIENCE DERSTAND.
THIS I
AAROUL>> THEY FOREVER ON THESEG
WAVES, YOU KNOW.
I JUST SAW OTHER DAY THA
"BREG
NETFLIX.
I MEAN, IT'S SUCH COMMONEN
AND INTE A LOT OF
STREAMERS, THEY KNOWT THEY
HAVE BEEN INH NOYIE JUST FAIR W
PEOPLE TND
IT'S ON LI AND A IF YOY
, YOU IN, BUT THE SCALE ISO R
Y DIFFT LS TO CODDLE TOGETHER T
MAKE A LIN
OF THOSE DO THAT.
WELL, OSD
AWAY WHAT WAS CALLED NEW YE THE
BE PARATCOT,E STREAMINWARS
A
WHERE THE P IS
AND WITHTRACOFFERS TO ATEVERYTH.
THISIND ABLY SO WE NEED TOK
TUATTION
THAT
WE'RE PLAYIN AUP
MENTS THAT ANSWE THATLE.SOHEPLE
20EY SHOW TH RGE URAHE SAME TIM
T UP ONLY
TREMENDO E WORKIATHEMATICIAN T D
ATICKNOW ONE OF THE OTHER BIG  .
T TO, KNE RAAY S AND THE
ITAS PUB THAOW BEING
GUARDED.
>> T